elon musk ist in deutschland und möchte
sich heute sein werk vor den grenzen von
berlin anschauen gegen 15 uhr soldat
sein aber einer ist schon da und zwar
das tesla kennt und genau mit ihm möchte
ich jetzt sprechen sie das heineken mir
nun zugeschaltet sie lassen wie lange
bist du da heute schon und vor allem
warum stehst du heute da an dem noch
nicht fertigen werk hallo ich bin heute
hier und ich war sehr gespannt darauf
dass endlich mein idol
dann macht ihr einfach weil ich ihnen
gern einmal persönlich kennenlernen
möchte warum ist ihrer maske für dich so
ein held er ist ein held für mich weil
er ein großer visionär ist der viele
große ideen hat hier umgesetzt hat
facebook und fest lassen mal seine
beiden meine lieblings unternehmen und
ja du hast ja sogar schon mal indirekt
kontakt mit ihm zumindest über twitter
hat er dir schon mal sein respekt
ausgesprochen gesagt du das gerne mit
dem projekt weiterführen da hast du mich
die bauarbeiten von diesem werk gezeigt
was wir jetzt für dich so zu sagen der
nächste schritt mit seinem idol eine
maske
sind wir gespannt ob du diesen
praktikumsplatz heute bekommen wir
drücken auf jeden fall die daumen heben
das ganze spaß